adrien lemaître et là c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
alors je n'irai pas la pression il a été
très bon pilote
alors ça on stocke pas ça suffit
pression vous avez été excellent pilote
j'espère que je vais être bon parce que
pilote n'a pas été diffusé en revanche
pas aux coyotes si vous pouvez être
concentré sur ma chronique ce serait
très sain parce que j'ai travaillé
depuis 24 heures il a fait une chronique
ceyrat windows alors que tu vas me
raconter alors bonsoir à tous je suis
très heureux c'est chez les femmes on
apprend d'abord à dire bonsoir bonsoir
il que nkunda janin qui m'a appris
pendant huit ans sur 1 400 et 1
christophe pendant les trois dernières
saisons alors je suis très heureux
confié représentés enfin je suis plus
surpris que supris parce que comme on
vient de le dire je suis un des rescapés
des pilotes qu'on a tourné la semaine
dernière alors je vous explique le
principe de ma chronique je vais vous
faire un feedback
enfin plus un taux pour un briefing sur
toutes les news les morts les mecs
l'access prime time csa et ces deux mots
trois mois anglais réunion allait en
gros c'est ce qui s'est passé dans la
journée c'est le flash back
regardez
et on commence avec la matinale d'europe
1 ce matin présenté par nikos aliagas ou
qui ne s'attendait certainement pas se
faire embrouiller par un coach en
orthographe l'écouter quand vous dites
je lui vous n'accordez pas je ne vous
accordez va t'en vas jouer nous sommes
téléphonés le dit quoi je le téléphone
je lui téléphone huit téléphones nous
sommes téléphonés pad est i se sont
baissées vous direz quoi jeu articulé
bien en vue dans la nuit c'était sur bfm
tv lors la tranche de bruce tout ça qui
a fait un sujet sur le rappeur booba a
le sujet booba plus de deux millions
d'albums vendus des concerts qui font
salle comble le sujet c'était ça on
voyait un jeune un fan qui parlait de
booba on voyait le patron d'une radio
rap mais le plus savouré ce sont les
réactions de bouma qui regardaient le
reportage en direct de chez lui écoutez
ces commentaires très savoureux
[Musique]
mais dubaï n'a pas regardé que bfmtv
aussi ont regardé la première de thé pmp
en exclure on a les images regarder
alors hier sous les avais je sens une
fibre il y avait donc l'émission
préférée de joey starr l'amour est dans
le pré c'est fini je vends entre les
deux oui c'est fini depuis que j'étais
tout à l'heure vous allez voir il ya
booba cac lâche et joeystarr c'est
exceptionnel je crois que tu là je suis
je crois plus frais possible et je crois
que l'on inscrive du dugas alors l'amour
est dans le pré vous savez c'est cette
émission il n'y a pas que les vaches qui
sont en chaleur
il ya aussi les agriculteurs regardez
ces shows comme dans le slip de matthieu
delormeau c'est la digne aux conneries
c'est une bonne victoire
madame karine aussi devient de plus en
plus cool avec les agriculteurs on
dirait quasi ses potes de bar du pmu du
coin
mekhissi cpc des petits trous et avant
les questions de karine c'était hyper
carrés au bout de la treizième saison
elle est beaucoup plus cool à l'ats
carine à écouter ses décolletés quitté
la mairie gros nichons et en même temps
envoie opel se lâche complètement la
carie maintenant moins d'un centimètre
[Musique]
20 centimètres ça peut vraiment faire la
différence en matière de séduction
alors c'est à dire qu'elle précise ses
lavoirs c'est à dire ça a été écrit ça a
quand même été diffusée alors justement
tout à l'heure ce sera l enquête de ba
ba du jour l'amour est dans le pré
manipule tels les téléspectateurs
puisque vous l'avez vu hier soir était
diffusé un nouvel épisode on a pu voir
dans l'émission raul éleveurs donc sur
l'île de la réunion qui embrasse les
embrasser sa prétendante et apparemment
ils se connaissaient avant pas ce cap a
priori maintenant les meufs contacter
les prétendants avant on vend on a parlé
ça ça fait couler mais pas de lancre ça
a fait couler mais dd ddt stylo de ces
quatre couleurs en tire ou pas mais
c'est vrai nous c'est toi qui a préparé
l'émission je te rappelle que les
produits avec toutes les équipes on a
aussi vu une prétendante dans la
nationale avec toutes les équipes sur
nocives une prétendante dans l'amour est
dans le pré qui a préparé une maureen
dubosc c'est à dire qu'elle a raconté un
truc dont tout le monde se fout la
pauvre elle a écrit un poème avec plein
de rimes riches c'était sympa son poème
mais l'agriculteur il s'en fout
complètement
il essaye de ne pas mentir son ennui il
a du mal à ercis
je m'en fous
[Musique]
dans la foule je t'ai vu en vous
tous
je ne te quitteraient plus
oh les joueurs jeu
vous connaissez pas et on a cueilli sa
prétendante chez lui à la réunion raul
il s'est fait plaisir regardez bien
attention et sexy daniel a accueilli sa
prétendante chez lui et daniel sa petite
spécificité c'est quand il dit bonjour
il est dit jean marie le pen c'est assez
flippant écouter aujourd'hui vous allez
me savais qu'il y ait une mode
actuellement pour terminer chez les
personnes âgées c'est créer sa chaîne
digitale jusqu'au bout la mapi il a bel
art j'ai toujours eu du mal
isabelle isabelle morini du bonhomme
aurait dû du boss morini-bosc ans a fait
comme d'une machine voilà machine alors
en tout cas il y à une mode c'est créer
sa chaîne digitale c'est ce que vient de
faire
jean michel mr et bien évidemment avec
toute son élégance qui le caractérise il
a appelé sa chaîne youtube les amis je
suis super impatient et excité voilà ma
chaîne youtube à sortir très bientôt la
première chaîne but de france la
véritable digital c'est quelque chose de
très sérieux pour jour ni en témoignent
ces intervenants adopte une sommité du
monde médical
un docteur une sommité du monde médical
mais de qui parle-t-on
michel cymes jean michel cohen docteur
house il ya le docteur double take cloud
bull
jean-mi ce n'est pas la lourdeur mais
c'est aussi des moments suspendus et des
réflexions profondes avec moi
[Musique]
elle
comme une femme à les envies personne ne
peut l'arrêter
même pas la cia aujourd'hui aussi gens
me tient vraiment toutes les cordes à
son arc chroniqueur influenceurs
séducteur est aussi acteur dans une
vieille pub pour une cigarette
électronique tremble ben affleck
super merci sont beaux oui ces fruits
des bois j'aime beaucoup
tu sais il faut bien qu'on paie pour
faire monter le liquide oui regarde ça
elle est énorme
j'ai toujours un ego sur moi comment
dire démesuré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là